[The National Tuberculosis Association presents
"Cloud in the Sky"]
[Director: Edgar G. Ulmer, Director of Photography:
J. Burgi Contner, Sound: Dean Cole,
Film Editor: Marc S. Asch, Copyright MCMXXXIX by the National
Tuberculosis Association.]
[Narrator:] More than one and one half million
citizens of the United States claim Spanish
as their mother tongue. Their happy spirit
in the face of toil and hardship enriches
our land. They bear more than their share
of the crushing burden of tuberculosis. This
story is dedicated to them in the hope that
it will speed the day when our whole nation
shall be freed of man's ancient enemy, tuberculosis.
[Music and dancing while a priest and another man look on.]
[Priest:] You see doctor they are a very happy
people. Their old customs, their own language,
all of these things mean so much to them.
They work hard, it is true, but they certainly
do enjoy themselves.
[Doctor:] They surely do enjoy themselves.
By the way, it's late. I've got to be going.
[Priest:] Well, see you again, Doctor.
[Doctor:] Bye.
[ Music and dancing continue. ]
[Maria whispers to Priest [inaudible] and he gets up from the table.]
[Consuelo:] Father, what is it?
[Lopez:] It is your mother.
[Juan:] Mother had one of her coughing spells.
Blood came from her mouth.
[Inaudible] in there.
[ Music ]
[Names of the months in Spanish flash on the
screen: Marzo, Abril, Mayo, Junio, Julio,
Agosto, Septiembre, Octubre]
[Lopez:] Why don't you eat, my child?
[Consuelo:] I'm not hungry, father.
[Lopez:] You aren't sick?
[Consuelo:] No, don't you worry.
[Sounds of eating and then clatter of dishes being washed.]
[Father is shown at workbench, repairing shoes.]
[Consuelo approaches her father.]
[Lopez:] I am worried, my child.
[Consuelo:] Don't father...
[Lopez:] I can't help it. Since your mother
left [inaudible] a year ago. You have been
coughing. You don't eat. You feel tired. I
have watched you.
[Consuelo:] I'm tired yes. Maybe I'm still
growing...wouldn't that be funny? [She coughs].
[Lopez:] There, you see.
[Consuelo:] I see nothing. It hasn't rained
in so long there's dust in the road, some
of it got in my throat. I won't have you worry
about me. I'm all right [cough].
It's late. You have to get up early to go to work. Good
night dearest.
[Lopez:] Good night.
[ Background noise ]
[Lopez:] Tired she was. It's not the work-
and how she coughed, just so you [inaudible].
My dear.
[A woman is shown at a church altar. Consuelo sits in a pew. Organ music is playing. The priest looks at her.]
[Priest:] Consuelo, I have seen you praying.
Peace and consolation are the blessings that
our blessed mother gives to her children.
[Consuelo:] Father, I'm afraid. My mother
was taken from us and now I am ill.
I cough, I am tired all the time. I have the same signs that she had. Help me Father, help me.
[Priest:] Yes, Consuelo, I will help you. I
will give you the blessings of the church
and all the consolations of religion, but you
must take my advice. You must go to a doctor
at once.
He can and he will help you. You must not
use patent medicines. You must not use home
remedies. God has made us to understand and
to know. He has given us an intelligence.
He has also given us science and the doctors
spend their lives curing and helping those
who are ill and who suffer. God wants us to
use the gifts that he has given us from heaven.
You must go to a doctor Consuelo.
[Doctor:] Now let's see now.
[View of patient questionnaire: (n) Chronic
lower respiratory affections...none, (o) Ischio-rectal
abscess ..., (p) Pain... none, (q) Fever...
slight-afternoon, (r) Loss of weight (underlined)...
10 pounds, (s) Loss of ability to work...yes,
(t)Fatigue (underlined)... yes, (u) Sleep...,
(v) Night sweats... no, (w) Confined to bed...
no, (x) Delayed recovery other illnesses...
no]
[Next screen questionnaire continues: (a)
Cough (underlined)... slight - 5 weeks, (b)
Hemoptysis, date and amount... no, (c) Expectoration,
date and amount... slight, (d) Dyspnoea...
none, (e) hoarseness, frequent or transitory...,
(f) Chronic upper respiratory affections...,
(g) Sinus... normal, (h) Throat condition...
normal, (i) Teeth... ", (j) Appetite (underlined)...
very poor, (k) Digestion...]
Now come along young lady.
[ Background noise ]
Step up young lady, please, [your chin?].
This wonderful x-ray light goes right through
your body and makes a picture of the inside
of your chest on the film. Then we can see
if any damage has been done to your lungs.
With the ear we hear the sounds in the lung,
true- but the picture is even better and more
exact. With the x-ray we can now find tuberculosis
in the early stage before there are any other
signs. Step aside please.
[ Background noise ]
You know Consuelo if I had my way about it
every young person, no matter how well he
may be would be x-rayed, that may come someday.
[Lopez:] We do not know enough of this world
Pedro. If I only would take Consuelo's mother
to the doctor, but we are afraid of doctors.
[Pedro:] How should we know, nobody tells
us.
[Lopez:] That is what we think, but it is
not true. Men and women go around telling
us about the sickness. They try to explain
to us, but do we listen to them? No, we did
not even pay attention. Pedro, I know so well
the symptoms. Her mother had them too. Oh
I am so afraid.
[Lopez:] I must say this is a good way to
[attend your young man?]. Am I supposed to
entertain him or what?
[Consuelo:] Why not? He's going to be around
the house if I ever marry him.
[Lopez:] That sounds like my Consuelo! Give
it to him. Never allow a man to be too sure.
You look better now, I think the doctor has
helped you already but don't forget he will
tell me tomorrow all about how your lungs
look.
[Doctor:] See [Lopez?], all this is healthy
lung but there- a shadow, like a little cloud
in the sky. That means trouble beginning in
the lungs.
[Lopez:] I suspected it- like mama, like daughter.
[Doctor:] No, no tuberculosis is not inherited.
It is passed from one person to another. Now
let me show you what I mean.
Sit down over here. The
germs that cause tuberculosis grow in the
lungs of the person who has the disease. The
germs are very small; whoever comes close
to the mouth of the person who has tuberculosis
is likely to pick up some of the germs.
And once the germs are in the mouth of a healthy
person they may find their way into the lungs
-- this is how the seed of tuberculosis is
planted.
A mother kissing her child, a sneeze or a
cough, sleeping together, sick people spit
on the ground, a child later picks up the
germs on his fingers and carries them to his
mouth.
A sick person can be healed but in the meantime
he spreads the disease to many other persons
to whom he comes in contact. If he is cared
for in a sanatorium his diseases cannot spread.
[Lopez:] But what can I do?
[Doctor:] We will send Consuelo to a sanatorium
and there she will get well.
[Lopez:] Yes, I have seen them. They are beautiful,
but we are poor. Those places are for rich
people, not for people like us.
[Doctor:] No, no they're for all. All people
in an enlightened community know that tuberculosis
is not only a personal misfortune but that
it threatens every household.
Tuberculosis knows no lines of race, religion
or social status, so people gladly support
a sanatorium knowing that thereby their own
children will be protected.
[Lopez:] That sounds reasonable but can my
Consuelo be taken to such a place?
[Doctor:] Certainly, I will have one of the
nurses of the health department come to you
and make arrangements to take Consuelo to
the sanatorium.
[Lopez:] Thank you doctor.
[Doctor:] Never mind but there is one more
thing Juan and Maria must be examined also.
Tuberculosis in its early stages is without
symptoms so don't forget to bring them here.
I will make a tuberculin test first and if
that shows that the germs are in their bodies
then they too must be x-rayed.
[Maria:] It didn't hurt.
[ Background noise ]
[Man:] Everybody is talking about you and
your daughter. Is she really in one of those
sanatoriums?
[Lopez:] Yes.
[Man:] And how did you do it?
[Lopez:] I listened and did what the doctor
told me.
[Man:] I think you sold your soul to the devil.
[Lopez:] What do you mean?
[Man:] Well, you know he can make people do
what you want them to do.
[Lopez:] That's just exactly what I did.
[Man:] You mean that?
[Lopez:] Of course not, you are the most ignorant
man I ever saw. I listened and I learned and
that is the trouble with you, you are ignorant
and won't learn.
[Man:] You're just as ignorant as I am, but
you can learn, I can learn too.
[Lopez:] [Hey!?]
[Man:] What?
[Lopez:] You always spit on the floor. Of
all rotten things to do, you spit on the floor.
You dumb-bell.
[Man:] What is the matter with you [Lopez?].
I spit where I like, so do you.
[Lopez:] I do not. I know better, let me show
what the doctor explained to me. I have a
book and I want you to see it yourself. Come
on.
[Maria:] Consuelo, is she really going to
be well again?
[Nurse:] Of course she's looking splendid,
she's getting stronger every day.
[Juan:] Everyday Ms. [Oleze?].
[Nurse:] Certainly, why do you ask?
[Juan:] She's been at the sanatorium for nearly
a year, that's a lot of days. She sure must
be powerful strong by now.
[Lopez:] Juan, you should have it all figured
out. How do you do, nurse? You are so nice
to come so often.
[Nurse:] Well, I have to look after all of
you. Consuelo and the doctor always asks about
you.
[Lopez:] The children are doing fine- fresh
air, good food, plenty of rest, fresh vegetables.
You see we grow them ourselves.
[Nurse:] That's fine Mr. [Lopez?], the doctor
asked me to remind you however that it's been
nearly a year since Juan and Maria were examined
and he wants you to bring them in again.
[Lopez:] Certainly but would you mind to come
to my home and tell me how is Consuelo?
[Nurse:] That's a good girl. Well you'll be
going home soon, aren't you glad?
[Consuelo:] Of course but...
[Nurse:] But what?
[Consuelo:] I don't know how I can thank all
of you.
[ Pedro signing in Spanish. ]
[Nurse:] Oh, isn't that nice, I wonder who
it could be.
[Man:] [You cannot sing you have to move on.?]
[ Music ]
[Doctor:] Two years have passed since you
left for sanatorium. You have been a good
girl. I find that the lung is well-healed
now you may marry but remember...
[ Music ]
[Priest:] Remember doctor the last time we
were here, I remarked to you that these are
very happy people and now I add a very healthy
people.
[ Music ]
[The cast, Rosario De La Vega, R. C. Ortega,
F. L. Tafolla, Frederick J. Mann, C. Ss. R.,
R. Trevino, Jr., The characters in this film
are fictitious. Any resemblance to any person,
living or dead, is purely coincidental.]
[The generous services of friends, including
the Sidney Lanier High School, Tipica Orchestra,
Works Progress Administration, and Woodmen
of the World War Memorial Hospital are gratefully
acknowledged.]
[Music]
[ Silence ]